- Can you name this artist?
(catchy hip-hop music)
Sounds like Jay-Z covering
Nicki Minaj's "Chun-Li", right?
Or is Nicki Minaj just Jay-Z sped up?
This conspiracy has been floating around
for years and it's hilarious.
(catchy hip-hop music)
- What you're actually hearing
is the effect of pitch shifting,
the result of warping notes,
voices, and other sounds
to make them sound much
lower or higher than normal.
It's a common tool found in guitar solos
and hip-hop samples, even cartoons.
But how does it work and
why do people use it?
(dreamy pop music)
We're here with Dianna from Physics Girl.
(high pitch sound)
(glass breaks)
(gasping)
- My head is not (screaming)
- [Nahre] We were talking
earlier about what
musicians think of pitches,
as is basically like--
- A high note is a high
pitch, low note is low pitch.
So in science, we talk about those notes
as low and high notes, as frequencies.
So check this out.
If I sort of slide up,
I'm not a great whistler,
but if I start to slide up the scale,
like from low pitch to high pitch.
(high-pitch frequency)
What did you notice?
- The recording just--
- Yeah!
- They shrink, come closer.
- They got closer together.
So using a wavelength, which is related
to what we call frequency,
shorter wavelength is higher frequency.
It just happens more often.
- Is that what's happening
when we're pitch shifting?
We're just taking that and
scrunching the wavelengths?
- Yes, you would be just
taking your wave form
and squeezing it, making
those peaks closer together.
Or further apart if you pitch shift down.
- Before you hear our original song,
let's talk about how other artists
have used pitch shifting in their music.
("Chun-Li" by Nicki Minaj)
- When we made Nicki
Minaj sound like Jay-Z,
we slowed down the song to 130%,
which stretched out the
waves to lower the pitch.
Many artists have used
speed-altering techniques
to manipulate pitch in their songs,
but the band that really
pioneered this style
is one I'm sure you know.
("Bad Day" by Alvin and the Chipmunks)
Songwriter, Ross Bagdasarian,
was experimenting with the tape recorder
in the late 1950s and discovered a sound
that would define his career.
He used this technique to
create a duet with himself
in his hit song, "Witch Doctor" from 1958.
("Witch Doctor" by Ross Bagdasarian Sr.)
Then one day while driving
in Yosemite National Park,
a chipmunk dashed in front of his car
and well it all clicked.
(popping sounds)
He recorded the vocals
for Alvin and the Chipmunk
at half the normal speed
and played the tape back at full speed
to create the effect.
Here's how they sound when you slow
a chipmunk song back down
to it's original speed.
(slow a cappella music)
♪ Where is the moment
we needed the most ? ♪
This technique wasn't new.
For example, it was used in
1939 to give the Munchkins
of the Wizard of Oz their unique sound.
- Follow the yellow brick road.
- It was also used for cartoon
characters like Tweety Bird.
- I thought I saw a pretty cat.
- Pitch shifting wasn't only used
for cartoons and magical kingdoms,
Chuck Berry didn't want
to sound like a chipmunk,
but his record label did
speed up his recording
of "Sweet Little Sixteen"
just a little bit,
so that he sounded younger.
("Sweet Little Sixteen" by Chuck Berry)
When creating The Beatles's
"Strawberry Fields Forever,"
John Lennon wanted to use parts
of take seven and 26,
but due to so much
experimentation in the studio,
the two parts were recorded
at different tempos and in different keys.
Producer George Martin
slowed one tape down
so that the two matched.
You can actually hear
where the splice happens.
Listen to the shift right before
John Lennon says, "Going to."
("Strawberry Fields
Forever" by The Beatles)
You might've noticed John Lennon's
vocal tape was slowed down,
which is why it sounds
dreamier, almost slurred.
In more recent years,
producers like Kanye and Just Blaze
took notes from Ross Bagdasarian
and sped up soul and R&B samples,
adding a new Alvin and the Chipmunks
kind of flavor to their beats.
("Through the Wire" by Kanye West)
- There's another way to affect pitch
without adjusting the timing at all.
Artists like Jimi
Hendrix use guitar pedals
to digitally affect
the pitch in real time.
In his song "Purple Haze",
he played the guitar
through a pedal called the Octavia,
which electronically doubles
the frequency of the notes
that are being played,
so that they sound an octave higher.
(high-pitch guitar riff)
In more recent years, Jack
White used the guitar pedal
called the Digitech Whammy
to do the exact opposite.
Because The White Stripes
lacked a bass guitarist,
Jack White pitched down his guitar
to sound like a bass in the
song "Seven Nation Army".
(bass guitar riff)
Artist have also used pitch
shifting to fix mistakes.
Auto-Tune was invented in
1997 to hide studio errors.
Notes that were sung a bit off
were no longer going through a take.
Producers were able to shift frequencies
of notes to make everything
sound perfectly in tune.
- But then on October
19th, 1998, this happened.
("Believe" by Cher)
Auto-Tune evolved from the audio version
of white out into an instrument itself.
Cher didn't use it to
cover up her mistakes.
Instead, she used it as a vocal effect.
Some purist still deride it
as a crutch or a gimmick,
while others like Radiohead,
Lil' Wayne, and T-Paine
saw it as another tool
to make something unique.
- When singer, Casey Dienel, claimed that
Justin Bieber and Skrillex's song "Sorry"
infringed on the copyright
of her song "Ring The Bell,"
Skrillex took to Twitter
to show that he didn't steal the song,
but actually used pitch shifting
to create the song's chorus in a way
that made it a very close match.
- [Skrillex] Now take this
♪ Ooooooh ♪
Pitch it up 12. See my talents.
- In recent years, there has been a wave
of choruses that feature vocals
with raised pitches and fragmented parts
with producers contorting the human voice
into catchy but alien-sounding hooks.
Think Major Lazer's "Lean On"
(catchy pop music)
or Skrillex, Diplo, and
Bieber's "Where Are U Now."
(catchy pop music)
- What do you think we can
do with the pitch shift song?
- Maybe taking a sample
of someone talking,
because there are pitches
that if you really examine it.
- Yeah.
- What if every element of the song
is pitch shifted in song way?
- I feel like it's gonna
sound really trippy
because everything, every part of,
there's nothing familiar in there anymore
because everything has been altered.
- Trippy is good and is instant.
Trippy is great. (laughing)
- I hope it sounds trippy.
- I have the clip of
Dianna speaking right now.
- Push it.
- Let me play it.
- [Dianna] I'm Dianna from Physics Girl
and you're watching Sound Field.
- We should use her definition of pitch.
We can start the track just to give
the clips of context but then
gradually pitch shift it.
- Alright, so.
- [Dianna] Pitch is the
frequency of the sound wave,
which tells you how
often your wave is moving
back and forth. Your wave
is moving back and forth.
- Your wave is moving back
and forth, back and forth.
(laughing)
- Back and forth, back and
forth, b-back and forth.
Back and forth. Back and forth.
(table hitting)
- Okay.
- We have our track. (laughs)
(electric synth music)
- [Dianna] Pitch is the
frequency of the sound wave,
which tells you how
often your wave is moving
back and forth. Wave is
moving back and forth.
(electric synth music)
- As for Jay-Z and Nicki Minaj,
well Jay is the one that wrote,
Death of Auto-Tune, to protest
all this pitch shifting.
But then again, if he's
Nicki's ghost rapper,
wouldn't that be the right
move to throw us all off?
(hip hop music)
- [Nahre] I've been hearing
this sound everywhere.
- We just want to give a
shout out to, that's Tayo O
for taking the beat we
do on our trap episode
and remixing it and rapping over it.
Check it out.
("Black Cronkite" by Tayo O)